they're facing a tough one at max who's
been really good lately coming off a
nine inning complete game 90 pitches
pitch
swing and a miss freed got him with a
curveball his first strikeout and after
the hit batsman two up two down here's
buster posey oh yeah
there goes slater got a good jump the
pitch taken and the throw is not nearly
in time so even with that good pick off
move austin slater gets the steal
we'll see if posey can put the giants
ahead tonight
he swings away and hits a high fly down
the right field line toward the corner
it is gone
straight down the line and it just gets
over that tall wall buster posey
max freed can't believe it his 16th of
the year
two nothing giants
and that one a diving stop ozzy
tries to skip throw to first and he got
his man what a play wow spectacular play
by ozzy albies through his tire wilmer
flores
and the giants settle for two with the
giants ahead two nothing before kevin
gausman even throws a pitch company
faces jorge soler rifles that one into
left field on the first pitch
might be a good plan of attack jeff this
guy doesn't give up much with two
strikes so don't get there if you can
avoid it and the pitch is hard hit into
that field of base hit
solaire around second he's gonna slam on
the brakes
and gossman's given up
two singles to atlanta and dansby
swanson's coming up rain begins to fall
in atlanta as we said it's a very muggy
night and braves grounds crew is going
to scramble down to the tarp and get it
uncovered we're going to have a delay
first base umpire calls ed mangan in the
grounds crew mark carlson says cover the
field and dansby swanson has a 2-2 count
at 8 16 eastern time delay started at 7
41. two on two out full count runners
will be moving with two outs
and it's up the middle bouncing ball and
everybody's gonna be safe infield hit
for dansby swanson
[Applause]
that one right to first knocked down by
ruff who just moved over to first base
and he'll ditch it off to gausman for
out number three so after all that that
was a long first inning giants have a
two-nothing lead so now mike kustrebski
3-2 pitch is lined into center field a
base hit stremski jumping all over that
3-2 fastball shoots it into center and
the giants have a lead off base runner
here in the second inning the rain delay
might have affected him
that one pulled into left and it's going
to get down base hit so tyro estrada
backs up the ostremski single with a
single of his own the giants have two on
nobody out
so now gosman with one out i would
imagine a bunt situation even though you
look at the numbers kevin has eight hits
bunts it and he got it down darneau is
going to go to third and he throws it
away
yostremski will get up and come in to
score it's three nothing giants estrada
makes it to third that was good base
running by tyro there
gausman stays at first that's a gift as
adam duvall will lead off here in the
atlanta second three balls two strikes
high fly ball wallop to deep left field
at the track
it's gone
adam duvall gets the braves on the board
with a solo home run
[Applause]
wade doesn't get a breaking ball from
max freight he strikes out to start the
top of the third inning
see roster goes from 26 to 28 guys as
rough swings and misses freed has
back-to-back strikeouts and three in
total here in the third inning oh he got
rough on a curve ball last time this
time almost same exact spot
a swing and a miss max free just struck
out the side that's a nice comeback for
max
sporting a 393 on base this year what a
campaign to pitch
and he does the job gets the runner to
third
the peg to first is in time and austin
riley becomes the key man in the inning
solaire 90 feet away with one out justin
reilly singled his first time
shot to right it's a base hit and the
braves are down and run that's a thing
of beauty
he's an mvp candidate folks
and at bats like that are a big reason
why
on the ground and nobody's there so the
shift took away a hit from wilmer in the
first inning and here in the fourth he
says take that
two outs two strikes
getting that pitch count up and la
stella pulls that one down the right
field line now estrada's got a lot of
speed long way to go for solaire estrada
coming around third and he will score
tommy lestella meanwhile got hung up
so the giants get the run but instead of
gaussman coming up that's out number
three so tommy i don't know
he got caught in between somehow there
but the giants will take the extra base
hit and the run batted in their lead is
four to two
[Music]
got him swinging with the fastball
second strikeout for kevin gausman
strikeout total has been down tonight
just reach back heater at the top of the
zone ozzy wait for that splitter that
he'd seen the last two at bats he's
making kevin gausman earn this third out
in the sixth inning two and two
on the ground to first darren ruff will
feed to gazman out number three kevin
gausman very impressive tonight
he's retired 11 hitters in a row he had
the giants lead 4-2
ahead of mentor 2-1 that one hit on one
hop and it kicks past albie's who's
hurting a little bit that one caught a
piece of his hand i think so that should
be a hit i would think for tommy
listello that ball was hit hard tough
play that's a pretty hot shot it looked
like it caught him on the thumb
squares this pitch up
that kind of jumped on him a little bit
and ozzie tried to pick it think he was
going to stay low he ends up going up
catches the thumb rolls out into center
field and tommy les stella another base
hit big one
already a ground ball first pitch it
sneaks through for a base hit tying runs
around for atlanta
and now a chance for ozzy who's had a
tough night to do some serious damage
here in the home seven two on one out
swag and a shot hit to the gap that's
down and will score one here comes
heredia he's on his way to third wash is
gonna throw up a late stop sign
it's a double ferrazzi and the braves
are down a run oh baby he broke that
ball big fast ball featured by lately
first pitch swing of the drive deep left
field
has put the braves in front
he talked about him heating up
this was a no doubter
and just like that chip
two two pitches on two pitches it goes
from four to two
to six to four and now will smith's on
to get three more outs
[Music]
fastball hit high and deep to left field
duvall going back at the wall leaps it's
gone
wilmer flores makes this a one-run game
his 16th home run of the year
the giants are not done
listen to truest park tonight
fly ball right field peterson on the run
at the wall leaving 12.
what a catch jack peterson up against
the gate
what a way to start the weekend
you